[Music]
[Music]
all right
we're here please tell me if the
microphone is sounding okay today
should be okay i hope i recorded with it
not too long ago you got your riddick
goggles on that's just in case uh i got
i got that
they're actually my green ones they're
not my reading oh yeah that's right
these are my sexual tyrannosaur goggles
in case in case i have to become a
sexual
yeah they go they go with my sexual
tyrannosaur hats oh he's got a whole
thing
see i got a whole thing this whole
ensemble i might turn into a dinosaur
any [ __ ] moment
sexual dinosaur from another era
so yeah i might want to stay tuned for
that yeah [ __ ] watch out
man only fans
[Laughter]
yeah we'll start one of those one of
these days probably all kinds of [ __ ]
people out there to pay to see a sexual
dinosaur
oh i'm sure yeah including all of chuck
tingles fans
i have all these [ __ ] crazy ass gay
dudes like you're watching
my only fans be dressed up like a damn
dinosaur
yeah you need one of those big suits
dinosaurs just go around dinosaur doing
solo scenes and [ __ ]
sexy dinosaurs yeah [ __ ] zach could
pay for that i'm sure
i don't know if he was here you could
ask him i don't see it yet though
yeah all right so we're talking about a
movie right
yeah yeah so if you hear any noises in
the background it's because it's been
storming here
that storm yeah for two days so
hopefully like i saw some lightning and
[ __ ] earlier but i don't
i think the power should stay on but uh
yeah
yeah louis is saying the film that got
denise huxtable kicked off the cosby
show
you know what's weird okay so at least
according to the wikipedia page
i mean we'll get into this movie in a
minute uh and this is kind of about the
movie
because lisa lisa beaune is in this and
this was kind of her big film role
you know after she'd been on the cosby
show now
she had read the script so she knew what
it entailed because you know she's
naked a lot in this and um you know and
it's like
big sex scenes and stuff so apparently
bill cosby
said you know yeah you should be in the
movie but then after the movie came out
he didn't like it and so i think that he
contributed to
her getting kicked off the show because
he was like oh yeah they just put her in
the movie
uh you know should they so they could
show her having sex and doing voodoo and
stuff and i'm like bill cosby
where the [ __ ] do you get off like
telling well you know what that was
that's what i mean
you know what he was doing he wanted to
see it yeah he wanted to see it his
rapist ass
yeah that's what i mean so i was just
like shut up nobody listens then that
would happen
i thought i think first of all i think
this is a great movie it's a paranormal
kind of crime drama yeah it's like it's
like satanic
yeah which there needs to be more of
those i feel like
i saw it when it came out i i forgot
that it was a 50s period piece
yeah i just knew that it was in
happening like in the south down
in in new orleans and being from that
area
[ __ ] i i forgot that it was 50s
because it still looked like that in the
80s
it looked like you know well they did
shoot it in an actual i mean the place
where they shot it in new orleans it's
set
partially in new york city as well and
i'll kind of get into that but the place
they shot at new orleans was actually
kind of an abandoned like worker camp
or worker village yeah that wasn't far
from the way it looked in the 80s yeah
still in parts of it yeah not all of it
but uh it looked about like that
i forgot it was a period piece i
remember
we were kids me and all my friends were
talking about how [ __ ] hot at least
lisa bennett was
and she was very hot in this and it aged
well yeah she's
she very attractive very attractive uh
young lady
[ __ ] good sex scenes but you know she
was wild
she was she in that on on that huxtable
program you know what i mean she was
kind of
portraying kind of an all-american girl
but we knew even as kids that she was a
wild ass
she was kind of like angelina jolie
where you know i mean [ __ ]
nuts but fun so it wasn't really out of
character
for for her to do this movie from our
point of view
it was a good role for her i thought she
was great at this yeah i think
i think older people were shocked but
[ __ ] man older people are always shocked
at what young people do
they're always clutching yeah oh my oh
oh my god
[Laughter]
but to us it was just yeah right on yeah
god damn look at that you know we were
just i remember what it was like
[ __ ] you know yeah well yeah a lot of
guys liked her you know [ __ ] white
guys and black guys liked her you know
she was of course she was looking
kind of you know she was mixed so she
was you know she was attractive you know
everybody liked her like i said she was
you know it's not a huge part in this
but it's
you know it's it was enough to make you
see the movie she was
she was what called people to the movie
yeah but it was a good movie when you
saw it
it's filmed very well the acting's
really good robert de niro is a
it's a i forgot how young de niro was in
this in 87 yeah in 87 he still was a
young man
us we thought it has thought of him as
an old man
but we were kids yeah but look at him
now he's like what maybe 40
yeah maybe yeah maybe 40. and like a
well-preserved 40.
played a pretty good devil yeah pretty
good yeah
so okay so this came out this is angel
heart by the way this came out in 1987.
now what ended up happening with this
okay so i think that a couple of y'all i
don't remember who it was but a long
time ago
somebody requested oh you guys should do
a movie retrospective on angelhart
and i was like oh yeah i remember seeing
that i either saw it on cable
or i rented it like back in the late 80s
or early 90s somewhere around there
probably when i was in high school
and i remember really digging it but i
couldn't remember a lot about it
other than robert de niro's the devil
there's voodoo in it
and that's kind of and it was like a
noir that was like all i remembered
but i remembered it being really cool so
when
you guys first um asked about it i was
kind of like looked it up and it was
really hard to find on any of the
streaming services i'm like what the
[ __ ] either you had to like pay really
you know expensive to get like a blu-ray
or whatever and i said well [ __ ] it so i
put it on the back burner
but then i realized like probably like a
month ago it turned up
on pretty much all the streaming
services i think it's on amazon prime
on free to me i think it's on hulu you
might be able to watch it on pluto tv
for free as well although that might
have ads
and i was just like well hot damn so i
put it in the patreon poll two or three
times but it never won
so finally like last night i was looking
around i was like what movie do i want
to talk about the matinee i'm like you
know what [ __ ] it i'm going to re-watch
angelhart because i haven't seen it in
such a long time
and i want to see if it's as good as i
remembered and guess what it was even
better than i remembered yeah a lot of
people were saying that
it aged really well watching it reminded
me
watching it reminded me of uh that first
season of true detective
yeah kind of a lot like true detective
kind of kind of had some of the same
visual
styles to it although same area but
different different uh
time period this is a beautiful looking
movie yeah i forgot how beautiful it was
um alan parker directed this uh if you
guys don't know he directed all kind of
[ __ ] he directed a pink floyd the wall
um he did [ __ ] uh fame evita
uh midnight express mississippi burning
um all that kind of stuff
so he's done all kind of different stuff
he just died last year i think
which is why because i saw like a lot of
uh you know horror blogs and stuff like
revisiting this recently
and that's probably why because alan
parker died not too long ago
now this was actually based on a novel
that came out excuse me in 1978
called falling angel by william
hortsburg and um pretty much as soon as
the novel came out and it was kind of a
hit
and so he started he wrote like a
screenplay treatment of it
and was shopping it around to different
uh studios now i think paramount had the
rights for
a time and they were gonna make it but
then they kind of lost interest or
whatever
and so it took a really long time to get
it made
interestingly the book i haven't read it
but i read like a couple synopsis of it
interestingly the book the whole thing
takes place in new york city
in this one it's kind of like you know
new york in the first half or the first
third of it and then the rest of it is
in new orleans oh you put your glasses
on
yeah i didn't even notice you doing that
i'm going back in time to the dinosaur
era
i'm in
[Laughter]
all right yeah grampur's hammer said uh
louis cipher lucifer were you surprised
when that was revealed no
no we saw it coming i mean everybody now
it now interestingly okay so so they
changed a couple things like i said from
the book the book the whole thing's in
new york city installed voodoo and stuff
like that in it but it you know it was
kind of different
they also changed a little bit about the
character
of harry angel who's like the main guys
played by mickey rourke in the movie
they made him kind of more sympathetic
and they also kind of switched around i
mean
it's not okay so it it's not a twist
that robert de niro is the devil i mean
duh
obviously and pretty much the first
scene you see him because he's not in it
a lot he's only like in three or four
scenes he turns up periodically
the first time you see him you know
there's something like [ __ ]
creepy about the dude um you know he's
got long ass fingernails he's like you
know spooky looking and he's got the
[ __ ]
cane and whatnot and he says he's i'm
looking for this dude it's like talking
about souls
contract and talking about souls and
stuff like that and so it's like you
pretty much know he said
so that's not even a twist i don't even
think and i don't even think that was
intended to be a twist that he was the
devil i mean because it was obvious from
the outset
what was a twist should we even spoil it
i don't know
because it came out in 87 though the
thing is though is like
for a lot of younger people this this
would be classic theater
classic cinema so you know i mean you
might be kind of robbing them
of the opportunity to see this movie
this movie is
a very artistic movie but it's not so
artistic
that it's elevated out of the realm of
the average person to appreciate it
it's shot really well yeah it's gorgeous
yeah this where it's set the setting is
pretty
uh cool you know broken down bad areas
of
[ __ ] new orleans in the in new york
they shot a lot of it in harlem
yeah in the 50s okay and uh this
private detective he's going to kind of
like these black neighborhoods
in investigating this [ __ ] and he meets
up with this
lisa bonadis hot ass [ __ ] i don't
probably call her quadroon
quadruple octoroon girl and
he starts an affair with her and just
the way it's shot you know what i mean
hot sex scenes her [ __ ] house leaks
[ __ ]
water through the roof like crazy but
they're still cracking
tearing it up the [ __ ] water coming
down in the house and
although that should actually be
happening we don't know what's it
it's you just gotta see it it's a very
because the thing about it this is a
very one of those movies
where it almost seems like a
straightforward narrative but it's
really not
um i'm not gonna say it's as out there
as something like mulholland drive or
something like that but there is some
kind of [ __ ] in this where there's like
one there's a [ __ ] ton of symbolism
and there's also a [ __ ] ton of stuff
where they do
where you think that things happen in a
certain order because of the way it's
edited but
it didn't actually happen in that order
and it's like hard for me to talk about
without spoiling like what the big
reveal is and i find out satanists are
involved and stuff
not that not that uh louis cipher is the
devil everybody knows that but it's like
i'm talking about the other
twist yeah you know what i mean so so
the story behind this
uh harry angel is a kind of a rundown uh
you know private detective in new york
city he gets contacted by this
apparently wealthy dude named louis
cipher played by robert de niro
and he says uh i'm looking for this dude
he was a very
quite a famous crooner back during the
war like back in the 40s
uh his name was johnny favorite and he
and i had a contract and he has
disappeared um he
suffered from shell shock during the war
he came home
they put him in a convalescent hospital
but i suspect that he had just
he's disappeared from there because he's
like i dropped by there to see where he
was and they were kind of cagey and
wouldn't tell me everything
so he's like i'm paying you money and i
want you to go find him
so the rest of the movie is hairy angel
traveling around talking to various
other people trying to determine the
whereabouts
of this elusive person named johnny
favorite
and as this happens he gets deeper and
deeper into
uh the occult de voodoo stuff and
it turns out too that every time he goes
and talks to a person and gets
information from them
uh shortly afterward they end up
murdered in a really really horrible
way um you know so like the first person
he's like shot through the eye uh it
looks like a suicide the second will
like one guy gets
his like his dick cut off and stuck in
his mouth and he's like strangled one
woman gets her heart cut out
so there's like all this so it's really
interesting because
it's it's structured very much like a
noir so it's almost kind of like
chinatown or something like that
but then there's like these horrific
murders and like horrific gore
in it and also like really really steamy
like sex scenes
so much so that when this movie first
came out and went like went through the
mpaa
they were gonna give it an x rating um
and alan parker appealed the decision
like a bunch of times he's like look man
he's like please don't make me because
he spent like four months editing it
because he edited it as well
and um and the sex scene was edited in a
specific way and he's just like i really
don't want to take any of it out
but mpa were like no you know you you
can't have it's too smutty
so he ended up having to take out 10
seconds for the theatrical release
although
i will tell you that i think when it
came out on home video and what dvd and
stuff i'm pretty sure they put that 10
seconds back in
there because i think that the um the
version that i watched on
uh amazon prime was pretty long i'm
pretty sure that that 10 seconds was
back in there
well because i think the only thing they
took out was the 10 seconds with
uh with mickey rourke very uh obviously
like
thrusting into yeah at least like it's
like
and all the blood dripping from the
ceiling it's not real explicit
no it's not it's not at all it's
artistically shy it's not pornography
no uh i wouldn't even really call it
eroticism
i mean it's kind of it's kind of a
steamy scene but it's not
they may i think they made a big deal
out of it i mean well yeah
um the the director thought that too
he's like that was the biggest [ __ ]
waste of time
yeah because you see stuff like that in
other movies there wasn't really
anything that special about it in terms
of
what actually happened or how it was
shot one of the weird
special was just lisa lisa [ __ ] she
was in the prime of her [ __ ] life
at that period she looked [ __ ] great
and in those days nobody
had seen what she looked like without
her clothes off and everybody was
wandering
especially everybody in my generation
back they were like wonder what she
looks like [ __ ] without that
that damn skirt on you know what i mean
and
you know she's like giving the fans what
they wanted she looked good
real good well and you have to think too
that when you're so
known for playing kind of a wholesome
sort of role like on a family-friendly
show right after a while that's you
really got to get sick of that and
just like man i just want to be in a
[ __ ] i'm going to you know cut open
chickens a little bleed all over me and
let my tits hang out and stuff like
especially that's not that's not how she
was as a person she was wild
she was kind of like she was she wasn't
as crazy as
uh as what's her name i just [ __ ]
mentioned her before
but i would compare to um um
[ __ ] the girl who could have played
[ __ ] lara croft uh angelina
and yeah i would compare her to angela i
compared her to angelina jolie angelina
was much crazier
in a bad way you know what i mean yeah
lisa bonet wasn't
crazy in in in she was she was [ __ ]
fun but she wasn't
that crazy you know but she's kind of
crazy yeah
yeah remember remember that all the
rumors have come up about
about around that time yeah yeah
wouldn't you run around lenny kravitz at
that time
or was it a little bit later i can't
remember when that was
i thought she was dating lenny kravitz a
little bit later
anyway it doesn't matter yeah i thought
though i thought that i think that's
what it was yeah i wish i would have
made a good pair
although lenny kravitz had a beautiful
daughter anyway well yeah she wanted but
she was in uh mad max
jury road well she's been another [ __ ]
yeah the girl's just cute yeah i
remember her from that
right but uh so yeah so how he ends up
well this is kind of some [ __ ] up too
[ __ ] too and all i'll say is i've seen
one particular plot point in this like
compared to old boy which uh
you know if you see an old boy you might
know what i'm talking about and if
you've seen this movie
but um what how he hooks up with lisa
bonet is that when he goes down to
uh new orleans he's trying like i said
he's trying to track down this singer
named johnny favorite who supposedly
owes this you know owes louie cipher or
something like or
broke a contract or whatever and now
he's trying to track him down
so he finds out that he had a mistress
named evangeline proudfoot and
when he gets down to new orleans he
finds out that she's dead but her
daughter
epiphany is still alive and epiphany is
the one that's played by
lisa bonet now lisa bonet i will note
was i don't know how old she actually
was when she shot this movie but she's
supposed to be 17
in the movie so she's considerably
younger than
mickey rourke but whatever they did it
was the 80s nobody really cared about it
um 17 in the south is older than the age
of consent anyway
yeah especially in the 50s in the 50s it
was probably 13
yeah consent me growing up there was
more like age of consent was 14
15. tammy and louie said she was married
to lenny kravitz for a minute she was
yeah
i thought she was yeah yeah but yeah
it's like i feel bad because i really
really
i don't know there's just so much going
on in this movie and it's like hard to
talk about without spoiling what the big
twist
is um even though like i said i saw it a
long time ago and i didn't remember
i remember you know i remembered that
robert de niro was the devil that's not
a secret
but i didn't remember what the big twist
was but
when i was watching the movie like i was
a third of the way into it and then i
remembered
you know what i mean yeah so this is one
two that i think is good to watch
multiple times like in close succession
because
once you know what the twist is it's one
of those ones where you can go back and
look at how it makes it like a richer
experience
like once you know how the end is and
like who everybody is
um and you can go back and watch it and
see like where all the [ __ ] happened
and some of the stuff too like you said
the with all the
blood coming down from the ceiling and
like some of the [ __ ] that happens in
the movie
um and that mysterious figure in black
that he keeps seeing
you're not it's kind of left ambiguous
as to
whether that person is really there
whether
some of that stuff is really there or
whether that's just the way that
um that hair that hairy angel is
seeing it because some of this stuff he
has
dreams that have this weird like um
imagery in it and sometimes the dream
imagery kind of bleeds over into what
seems to be reality
so this is one of those movies where you
really got to pay attention
to because there's a lot of exposition
because pretty much the whole thing it's
like a noir in the sense that
he goes to one person and then he gets
this information from that person that
person ends up murdered
however and then that leads him to
another person and he goes and talks
that so you really have to kind of
listen all the conversations
to figure out because it's kind of a
complicated story
you know what i'm saying yeah um so it's
one of those ones where you really
and like i said there's also a lot of
weird dream imagery and a lot of like
[ __ ] that's going on that
you kind of have to so if you see it
twice
knowing what the end is and the end of
the book
and the end of the movie are slightly
different but like i said i'll it'll
spoil it if i say what the difference is
but it's not exactly the same however
the author of the book
uh william korsberg interestingly he
went on
later because he wrote the novel and i
think he wrote the first draft of the
screenplay for this movie like when
it was in production a long time ago he
went on later and wrote the screenplay
for
legend the fantasy movie from 1985 with
tim curry you know
um and tom cruise and mayor sarah in it
so he uh wrote the screenplay for that
as well
but when the movie came out he actually
really liked it
he liked what would have been done with
the story and he said oh even though the
novel was set entirely in new york city
still with the voodoo in and everything
he said i was
actually considering putting some of it
in new orleans so i think it's cool that
allen parker actually did that
uh with the movie because he was
considering it anyway
interestingly so this movie it cost 18
million dollars to make
and it only made 17.2 million back
at the theater so it was kind of a
disappointment
um it was actually released by the
independent studio carol co which also
did all the rambo movies and
stuff like that back in the day i got
something i got to say but but back in
the day i used to get this one
and angel heart and serpent and the
rainbow [ __ ] mixed up a lot well
they're both kind of voodoo babies yeah
although serpent and the rainbow is said
in haiti yeah e4 mafia says this is one
of the last movies that make you work
look [ __ ]
normal looks normal yeah you just
mentioned that they were for the company
[ __ ]
made rambo mickey rourke and stallone
started hanging around a lot
together and i think they both went on
[ __ ] hgh and human growth hormones
distort your face
it distorted both of their faces they
were taking that [ __ ] somebody asked me
earlier you're taking that ach and now
that's
old school [ __ ] man make your [ __ ]
nose and lips get huge
[ __ ] [ __ ] your face up that's why
stallone looks so bad in rambo four yeah
great movie but he looked funny in that
he got his face fixed though
he kept working on it he fixed it back
he looks better but they don't do that
[ __ ] anymore
yeah that's what i mean like mickey
rourke actually looks he looks pretty
good in this i mean
for looking like he looks like you know
a run down drunken gum shoe or whatever
like he's supposed to but he's still
kind of like
kind of foxy looking yeah but oh man his
face is [ __ ] up now yeah after that
have you did you see uh the wrestler the
movie that he did
when was that 2009 maybe it was later
than that that was really really good
they were taking that [ __ ] because they
thought it was well
they thought that it was less risky than
anabolic steroids
[ __ ] no it's less risky it's a lot
easier on your heart but
side effects of [ __ ] facial
distortion that's not worth it
yeah yeah just just take less steroids
dude
and danny rolling ghostface says rorke
got his face mangled from boxing
yeah because he went through a boxing
day too and bad plastic surgery
yeah well the plastic surgery and
everything to fix to fix the [ __ ]
facial distortion from hd
they just don't admit what they do
because stallone didn't admit that that
was from hgh but everybody in the scene
[ __ ] knows about peds know that
that's
symptoms of hgh like your face getting
your face
grows you grow you gain mass in a
different way that you would say
you also gain mass in your face you also
your nose and your lips get you get real
liver lipped and your nose gets [ __ ]
big it's like a lemon
and you know there's a there's a uh some
female porn stars that were into the big
booties and big legs were taking that
and their faces got [ __ ] up
they had to fix those you know [ __ ]
ryan connor
okay she fixed it she fixed it though
but if you look at ryan connor she's a
[ __ ] badass porn star she's my age
she looks real young
big old button legs and she works out
but that's not
from some of it's from anabolic steroids
but a lot of it was from hgh it [ __ ]
her face up
she had a nose like a lemon for a little
while yeah i had to get a nose job
see no thanks like how the hell did that
nose get like that
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah cause she didn't
look like that when she was young
just man not worth it yes no don't mess
with that one don't don't mess with me
don't mess with that one yikes but yeah
so so when this came out like i said it
didn't make a lot of money but
honestly i think this is one of those
ones that
sort of aged like a fine wine it got
and critical reviews at the time were
kind of mixed
like i feel like nobody really
explicitly [ __ ] on it
uh roger ebert liked it i remember it
got nominated for a bunch of saturn
awards and stuff like that so and a lot
of people thought mickey rourke was
great in it
you know de niro was great at it but
everybody was great in it um
you know it got a couple negative
reviews nothing too bad but it just
didn't really seem to hit with audiences
but it was one of those ones
that you know as time went on after it
came out on
video and everything like that it really
became like a cult classic
and you know even big filmmakers like
christopher nolan and stuff he said oh
this movie was a big inspiration for
memento which was kind of his big for
his first big breakout movie
um so and so i feel like this was kind
of like a big inspiration for other
creators
as well so it was one that wasn't really
appreciated
all that much at the time but over time
it became a lot more appreciated which
is the best kind of movie i think even
though it's gotta suck like
when your movie comes out at the time
and nobody goes to see it you know
but uh you know that's kind of what ends
up happening with that one but i think
the reason why this aged so well
other than maybe the special effects
like with the um
with the satan eyes on the baby at the
end that looks a little
dodgy but there weren't a lot of special
effects in this
so it's it doesn't date it because of
that also i think because it was set in
the 1950s
and they did such a good job with this
with the production design and the set
decoration and everything like that they
shot it in real locations
but they still you know set designed it
to to look like the 1950s
because it looks so authentic to the
time period
it doesn't seem like a movie that came
out in the 80s
you know what i mean it seems like a
timeless kind of flick because it was
set in the 50s
it doesn't have any sort of 80s looking
[ __ ] to it
you know yeah because remember because i
feel like in the 80s you remember in the
80s there was kind of like a 50s revival
there was a lot of stuff you know even
like back to the future and stuff like
that
where you know and uh rockabilly and all
this kind of stuff
kind of made a comeback so everybody was
sort of into the whole 50s vibe right
so i feel like there were some movies
that came out in the 80s that were
supposed to be set in the 50s but still
totally looked like the 80s
this one is not one of those movies this
game is talking about hga hgh's human
growth hormone
it was big for a while but side effects
weren't that good
yeah yeah most people stopped [ __ ]
with it for probably for
for that reason well some of those
competition guys that would on
everything else there was just one more
thing they would add on to it
because you could gain another five
pounds yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you know some you know how it's like
these girls that [ __ ] have boob greed
where no set of implants is big enough
they're just so greedy they gotta have a
bigger set over
some of the competition bodybuilders
were like that [ __ ] already
huge what the [ __ ]
i gotta get another five pounds you know
then they die
you know yeah it's just too much [ __ ]
you're not supposed to be that big
well yeah i agree i respect their work
you know what they want to do but you're
just not supposed to be that big you
your heart just can't pump that much
blood to that yeah it's just a little
guy
yeah yeah fourth throwdown brought up
peggy sue got married i forgot about
that movie yeah that was also set in the
50s
but like i said a lot of the 50s like
set in the 50s movies that were made in
the 80s still had an 80s veneer to them
this one really does not i think because
largely it was filmed in real locations
and they didn't do that yes they did
some set design to make it look like the
50s but they didn't do all that much
just cars they picked places that
already looked like that
yeah um you know largely so they didn't
have to do a lot to it
and i just just everything about it
just really evokes that time period like
you in a way i kind of like forgot that
it was made in the 80s because there's
just like nothing 80s about it at all
which is pretty amazing but um yeah i
had forgot and i had forgotten too
how unsettling this movie is
in the sense that there's just something
about it that's just really kind of like
spellbinding
because i was sitting there watching it
and i was just kind of like i was first
thing i thought was like man i forgot
about how beautifully shot this movie
was
and like i said i saw it a long time ago
but i didn't remember exactly what it
was about i remembered it being sort of
like
a mystery and you know and voodoo and
stuff but that was all i remembered
and i just got sucked into it man and
then like all of these creepy
like the one scene where he goes to
that mission or whatever and like the
doors kind of swinging like that and
those two women
like in the sort of nun habits are just
kind of sitting there and they just sit
up and look at him it's just like super
super creepy
and there's all just kind of like real
unsettling imagery like that
and i think it's really really well done
like just this kind of slow
burn type of it's you know it is a
horror movie
right i mean you'd call it a horror
movie but yeah
it's it's a noir with horror elements
it's a noir mystery but it has horror
elements because they're arts because
there's some gory [ __ ] in it
like i call it a supernatural detective
thriller yeah
oh not so i mean there is gory stuff in
it but
it's i wouldn't call it a typical
hollywood horror movie not by any
stretch they imagined well now
more kind of like along the lines of uh
jacob's ladder maybe yeah some people
have compared it to that and
in the sense that it's it's not really
remotely the same
but it's the same vibe if that makes any
sense
yeah and grantham said lisa bonet dead
in bed freaked me out
yeah she got shot in the uh badge yeah
yeah there there's some cr some terrible
[ __ ] happens in this movie like i said
people's hearts get cut out
you know so there's there is some gory
stuff a lot of blood
you know but it's still a detective
movie though it is yeah
it's a detective movie and you're not
really sure with what you're seeing
you're not it's kind of like
you don't know if who's narrating this
story is being honest with you
be a good way well you don't know is
this an alternate is this an alternate
universe or what the hell what the
hell's happening
and you're not entirely sure that what
you're seeing is real that's what i'm
saying
are you crazy you know it's that kind of
deal like kind of like
jacob's ladder yeah or like serpent and
the rainbow had a little bit of that too
because this kind of does remind me a
little bit of serpentine
not just because of the voodoo but
because of you're not really sure of
what you're seeing
right because of the weird like dream
like imagery that pops up and you're not
sure if like the character is just
seeing that or if that's really
happening or whatever
like i said it's you know very early in
the movie when he goes to meet
first with louis cipher he comes into
this mission or whatever
and he goes up and the first thing he
sees is this mysterious figure in black
and he can't see their face
and they're scrubbing like all of this
blood off the wall who's calling it i
don't know
it's a starry night oh [ __ ] we don't
have time for that i
can't you can't talk i think the strong
point of the movie is uh the tone
yeah totally the movie's spot-on
acting's great
the edit's fantastic it's got a good
score
it's a noir movie yeah
you you you're not just watching it
you're kind of swimming through it
you're kind of enjoying it
you're not rushing the movie you're just
it's just taking you through this thing
it's just there's no way to describe it
it's the tone yeah
it has a very romantic tone even though
all those weird shit's happening i mean
romantic in terms of like the nostalgic
yeah
romance you know kind of like a dark
nostalgia to it in a certain way
but maybe just because it i saw it back
when it was new
yeah maybe i think i think the reason
why it didn't get made earlier was
because when he was shopping it around
to all of the um
different studios everybody wanted it to
have a happy ending
yeah which it doesn't learn
so it kind of reminds me of that movie
was one that had all the stained glass
it was taken to take him
wasn't that happening in chicago philly
it was not dead riggers
what flatliners flatliners the one where
they were all coming back
yeah but yeah they're coming back from
the dead but the thing is this flat
i think it's because it was kind of in
the same era but i mean visually
nah it doesn't it doesn't i'm just kind
of associating it
with that because of of when it came out
but it's at that level i guess you could
say oh no
[ __ ] it i'm gonna say
more like jacob's ladder and yeah
and um serpent in the rainbow yeah so i
mean if you like those kind of movies i
think you probably dig this as well
it's the best way i can because it's
kind of in that same right that same
general area
yeah and then and also this that
television series true detective the
first
season yeah kind of like that too yeah
but it's like i said if you're if you
definitely need to like immerse yourself
in it's got a great score i love like
all the music in it
um a lot of the people that they got
like to be in the bands like in new
orleans stuff those were actual
blues musicians i think even like dizzy
gillespie and still like that like tried
out for the [ __ ]
um you know so they so a lot of them
were kind of in the background
but it's just a really really cool movie
and i feel like
i don't know it comes up on some lists
of like best horror movies and stuff
but it's not a traditional horror movie
but i wonder why they don't do
more horror noir i mean you know there's
been some
but i feel like it's a largely
unexplored sub-genre
and that's a shame because i really like
noir movies and i really like horror
movies
ganthur says i bet tom saw this at
southgate cinema
all the two movie screens nah i saw that
dab showboat
showboat that was a dollar theater
because yeah we would just wait for it
to come out of the main theater and go
to the dollar theme that's what i used
to do too yeah i was broke
yeah or we were watching on our own on
with our own money yeah we were
teenagers you know
so you know you weren't going to ask
your parents for the money you're just
looking
you know instead of buying cigarettes
you bought cigarettes and then you went
to go see the buoy
yeah you know which is the same price
cigarettes were only 1.25 back then
maybe a dollar fifteen dollar ten for
the paw malls i remember those
and it would still seem like a lot of
money oh man a dollar ten let me
let me get a big let me walk up to show
boat
showboat was right behind uh um
well we didn't walk the show we did walk
showboats sometimes but then later we
were driving
because we got cars but that was uh
behind uh
danny's yeah denny's yeah
and then al the little goth girl is
working at tc but tcb wise
the yogurt oh my god do you know what's
funny
i just i just recorded a review
i just recorded a review for the grady
hendrix books book my best friend's
exorcism
which was set in 1988 and the girl
uh in the the main character she worked
at tcby also
yeah and that's what made me laugh
grandpa's probably remember there's a
little redhead
working in there little punk rock little
puck rocker who's probably about
five foot ten no she's probably a four
foot ten
little bitty thing bright red hair i
think her name was pam
second yeah yeah yeah pam i think her
name was pam
uh dean asked me have i read any robert
r mccammon yes i have
uh didn't he write boy's life
if he wrote that i read that a few years
ago and i
loved it and i'm gonna probably revisit
it for
my book review show um i know i've read
more than that but now i can't remember
what it is but yeah i've read several of
his books and he is awesome i agree
um how much are sigs in florida these
days
oh [ __ ] we haven't bought pack of
cigarettes in a long time i haven't
either
i think maybe the last time i bought a
pack of paw malls which is a couple
years ago
they're probably 250 huh no i think it
was three
something or four something was it that
much i can't remember
been a long time yeah yeah i mean you
know
yeah dean said yes he did yeah boy's
life was probably my favorite of his but
i you know i've read several but i can't
remember
like all the different ones that i read
um
all right so we have anything else that
we need to
discuss yes no
oh no just uh scrap this was saying yeah
you forgot about showboat that was in
riverview
yeah you sneak into the r-rated movies
all the time yeah
and he and then he tells me it's a
girl's name pam or trouble
so a girl's name rhonda and sherry we
know i know exactly who you're talking
about well i agree with that ron
and sherry because i knew girls named
all of those things and yesterday yeah i
dated both of them
i dated both rhonda and sherry rhonda
was ronda was the keeper out of that one
but it took him
didn't work out too many guys were
gunner for it
you couldn't take the competition hey
man you're not a man [ __ ] there's a
lot of young guys [ __ ] running around
at that time
was cute man so sherry yeah
not pam though pam was a little punk
rocker
and she didn't go to school with us she
went to school at another high school
she went to school i think in riverview
and uh she was just this little bitty
punk rock girl with [ __ ] bright
orange hair
i said it was red but it wasn't it was
orange yeah it was
orange yeah she was cute
yeah back then we had we had a dollar
theater daytona too at the daytona mall
which was the kind of the downbeat mall
down the street from the nicer mall
which was built in the late 70s or 80s
or whatever
and uh that was i don't think i saw
angelhart in the theater though
i think i saw it i rented it or i saw it
on cable
which means i probably saw it in
89 or 90 something like that because i
feel i graduated from 1990 and i
remember me and my friend used to
rent a lot of movies or go to the dollar
theater like right around 89 or 90
and 91. now graham i don't think i dated
sherry
just ronda but i remember i remember
sherry
there's another redhead yeah yeah
all right you ready to wrap it up yep
all right so
if you haven't seen angel heart i didn't
really spoil it
because i feel like a lot of people
haven't seen it it's a little bit of a
cult classic
um kind of good one under the radar came
out in 1987.
pretty sure you can watch it on amazon
prime for free and i think you can also
watch it on hulu for free and maybe
pluto
pluto.tv as well so go check it out if
you really like kind of voodoo movies or
like creepy noir movies
or [ __ ] that's like kind of underrated
from the 80s because i feel like it's a
really good one and not a lot of people
talk about it
so definitely go and watch it and uh we
will see you guys ooh tomorrow's
wednesday right all right so tomorrow
night we're doing the sidetrack show
so we'll get drunk and talk to you guys
about whatever so that'll be fun
all right so no sexual tyrannosaur today
oh hold on i'm gonna leave i'm gonna
leave
sex with that i'm gonna sign off as a
[ __ ] sexual
make it a god damn sexual i was like you
might as well like
do it she said she carried the hat i
can't i can't [ __ ]
remember all my duties at all the time
that's what i got you here for
like i well i have to remember all of my
[ __ ] and i have to remember
because she's got to remind me when to
because i'm tired all this become a
sexual dinosaur
so we will see you guys tomorrow evening
at 5 p.m eastern standard time for the
sidetrack show have a good rest of your
day
and we'll see you later bye